viens donc fermeture de la mosquée de
pantin a été prononcée vous le savez à
la suite de l'assassinât ignoble de
samuel pâtit pour les raisons que l'on
connaît et la justice administrative a
par deux fois de leur donner raison à
monsieur le préfet de seine-saint-denis
que je voudrais remercier pour l'instant
les conditions ne sont pas encore
réunies pour la réouverture de la
mosquée de pantin puisque le travail qui
est en train de faire aujourd'hui le
préfet de seine saint denis avec le
maire de pantin je veux remercier et
l'association cultuelle musulmane n'a
pas encore tout à fait porter ses fruits
un salon de encore d'individus de
sinistres individus sont dans la
gouvernance de la mosquée je sais que
les choses sont en bonne voie mais pas
encore tout à fait acceptable pour la
république
mais dès que un certain nombre de
sinistres personnages ne seront plus
dans cette gouvernance sommes tout à
fait prêts évidemment à ce que jeune
consignes à monsieur préfet six années
de réouvrir la mosquée de pantin
même avant le 24 avril date vous le
savez bien de la fin des six mois de
suspension autorisé par le tribunal